for a time there patriotism was a
four-letter word
having the country come into a crisis of
this magnitude
has helped bring out the best in
americans and i think that that's
fabulous for the next generation of
entrepreneurs that's what you're
optimistic about what are you
pessimistic about what got
worse everything else no mask mask
hoax no hopes the president told us i'm
the biggest patriot in the world
i'm putting on my mask you do too that
should have been tweeted out on day one
we did the writing shutting down that's
what you're saying the media is
a source of divisiveness nobody believes
the chinese data
nobody how come we've never shut down in
the past and we've had different
pandemics are we going to be scarred by
this as a nation
are you asking me i'm asking you the
greatest fear is that we
turn to some form of socialism other
countries will cook our goose business
travel is going to take a generation to
come back
a generation a generation to come back
technology's coming that's going to zap
everything quietly there's no chemicals
involved nada this is changing the game
by the way
are you buying these polls saying that
biden's gonna be trump you're president
you're not
god you're a maths fan if they start
being okay with kneeling what do you do
i'm no longer a mass fan could we
potentially have something close to
civil war if you don't like what's
happening in this country
do something about it but don't
disparage those who've died for you and
by the way ted cruz
put a mask on do you have plans of
running no
why not i'm not gonna answer your
question you just did
so the last time i had danielle de
martino booth here for an interview we
got a total of 15 million views all over
the world facebook youtube
everybody was contacting us and you got
to bring her back so we're bringing her
back
the last time was april 7th we're back
at it again for a second time danielle
thank you for being back
on vacation here and while we've got a
special surprise for everybody today yes
we have a special surprise at the end so
uh long drum roll but okay
cannot wait to do that at the end so
opening question from the last time we
met
to today april 7th to three and a half
months later
what's changed both what you feel
optimistic about and what are you
more pessimistic about in the last three
and a half months so
optimism pestimism um
we have seen in the past few months
i think the best that america can be
i believe that in the aftermath of the
great depression we saw
the country come together and we've seen
that on so many levels over the past
few months we've seen people's hearts
open up we've seen people's wallets
open up it's just it's been
tremendous you know it for for a time
there
and we're still at risk of this you know
patriotism was a four letter word
and i i think that having
the country come into a crisis of this
magnitude
has helped bring out the best in
americans
and along the way we're
discovering our innovative inner selves
there are going to be
generations of new types of companies
that come out of this
and the the trend towards
how we receive services in this
country's accelerated
exponentially and i think that that's
fabulous for the next generation of
entrepreneurs
they've got massive opportunity
that's what you're optimistic about what
are you pessimistic about what got worse
in the last everything else
hundred days everything else what's the
biggest one out of everything
um the lack of coordination
okay the lack of coordination is going
to cost
this country countless small businesses
and that's where my focus is my focus is
on the backbone of the country
and the small business owners who
wanted to hold on for dear life
for a successful coordinated
thoughtful well-led reopening
who are having to reclose again and
that's it they're calling it a day
now a successful person cannot be
stopped
by one failure
these people will come back but it's
going to be a huge setback that
it wasn't necessary it would it didn't
have to be the way it is right now
because we're we're going from having
optimism about a v-shaped recovery to
knowing full well that we're going into
a w
and there's no way to stop it not even
though you're going to a w
we are going into a w shape there's
absolutely no doubt about it
absolutely no doubt so what wasn't done
prior what what could have been done
better in the way of handling the
original no mask mask hoax no hoax
coronavirus slow down
what could have been done better the
president told us today
the president is on the wires today
he has a mask on he has said he's
tweeted it out himself with a picture of
a mask
it has come to my attention that if
there's not an opportunity to social
distance
if that's just not there then wearing a
mask is
the next best thing so i'm the biggest
patriot in the world
i'm putting on my mask you do too he
tweeted it out today
that should have been tweeted out on day
one that should have been where it
started
it it should have never been on day one
what is day one
well unfortunately medicine and science
don't behave the way we want them to if
his closest medical advisors
scientific advisors flip the switch for
whatever reason they felt like pp was
available in abundance for whatever
reason if the people because you have to
rely on experts you're not
you're president you're not god so you
you're allowed to rely on the people you
put around you
but the day that it was decided that
maybe masks are
better we're looking at other countries
and we're seeing their example
they're having an easier time closing
down they're having a much easier time
much
more importantly reopening masks are
better the science was still on both
sides
but on that day had he gone with his
closest advisors
there would be millions of people who
would be able to keep their jobs
and it's as simple as that how much of
that is on him how much of that is on
fauci
well again he's fouchy did
terrible damage to to the cause of masks
coming flat out and saying that they
were not necessary
um when it was decided that that was a
mistake
it needs to have been sung from the
hills
this was a huge mistake on mar on my
part mia culpa
but please trump or fauci fauci okay
but please in all humility
please listen now please listen to me
now and you know what listen to my
equivalence around the world
listen to my equivalents in other
countries look at the examples of other
countries
that are going to reopen much better
than we have germany take to take but
one example
don't listen to mia if you don't if
you've lost confidence in me listen to
them
look at their example and then make the
decision
to not have it be a patchwork approach
from one state to the next look this is
still a baby virus
we are living under the assumption that
it is agnostic to heat
well i am sorry but it is 96 degrees and
they just raised the level in
brownsville texas to a level four
because their hospitals are overwhelmed
this virus doesn't give a damn about the
heat
maybe it's even angrier when you get to
the cold
we don't know until we get to the fall
but it's still a baby virus
but it's raged through much of the
country and
i don't look at this from a scientific
perspective and that is what gets
well i don't know 99 of my twitter
followers so angry
i don't i won't look at this from a
scientific perspective because
i'm not a medical doctor i'm not an
epidemiologist and i never will be
what i know is that the media is
a source of dissension in america and
divisiveness
the mainstream media so every single
time i cite
a source i go to this website called
media bias fact check and they have a
spectrum
the wall street journal is right of
center leaning cnn's probably
way on the left i don't know i don't
ever cite cnn per se
but gallup polls which has been around
since 1935
is smack dab in the middle not biased
period end and i find it to be a great
resource especially as we get closer to
elections because a lot of polling is
biased
so late april
gallup did a poll and they queried
americans based on their age
based on their political affiliation
based on their educational level
what do you feel is the efficacy of
masks yay or nay
well 41 of college graduates
believed in masks so
i then because analysis is about
connecting the dots
not looking at different sightings in
vacuums
so i connect that 41 percent or 46
percent of post-degree holders
and i look and see what they make what
their what their incomes are
these two cohorts go into the top
fourth and fifth quintiles of income
earners in america
80th to 100 60 to 80
top 20 percent of america just about 40
of america top 40
america top 30 of american earners okay
they are responsible for 61 percent of
consumption
us gdp is 75 consumption put differently
the people who believe in masks forget
the science
the people who believe in masks are
responsible for 42 percent of you
us gdp fear
and i know you i know you know about
fear and i know you
cannot stand fear fear is powerful
if i'm joe q american with the greatest
spending power
and i'm afraid to come out of the door
the economy is going to stop and you
know what the economy has stopped
because they're afraid to come out now
there were certain places in germany if
you decided to go out and in
in a public place without a mask on
that's fine you need to get get out your
wallet and pay a 10 000
euro fine you make up your own mind
their restaurants are open their
restaurants are open 20
over 2019 at this time right now
fine wonderful people are like 10 000
euros oh wear the mask
but the country's economy is open and
you've got your spenders out there
spending
we don't have that in the united states
of america and that means
that small business owners who are
in neighborhoods of wealthy people have
disproportionately gone out of business
say that one more time dry cleaners
restaurants in the highest
zip codes in america small businesses
and highest
wealth of america they've gone out of
business disproportionately why
because the people who they serve are
afraid to leave their homes
so okay by the way the way you process
that was very logical i mean it's just a
pure way of reasoning
and brown university have come together
because real-time data is very hard
to come by so they've created a national
repository that is free
and you can follow all of the data based
on
highest middle and lowest zip codes
lowest income earning zip codes
in the lowest income earning zip codes
the recipients of the six hundred
dollars
extra per week that's 15 billion dollars
a week of fiscal stimulus
in this one six hundred dollars extra a
week in unemployment insurance
that's part of the cares act in the
lowest income
zip codes the bottom third spending
through july the 11th was down 1.8
percent
since january not even really a blip
right that's not even a result no it's
not
okay in the highest zip codes spending
was down 11.8 percent
that's a recession i see what you're
saying so what you're saying is
the the top 40 educated these are folks
that maybe have a degree they're they're
making decent income
uh and they're doing a little bit more
research than maybe the bottom would
and they can work from home and they can
work from home they're spending
less the 11.8 versus the 1.8 which is
pretty much 10x that
give or take it's i think it is 10x that
to be exact as 10x that
that's a pretty scary number right there
uh uh
ten pointers about seven times six times
it's a big number let me go back to what
you said with fouchy and trump okay
because this is something that comes up
a lot
so faux says masks are not effective
okay and even you see fouchy when he
uses the mask when he was
uh being grilled i think by uh rand paul
and rand paul's saying who are you to
tell us where kids shouldn't go back to
school and he's touching his mask
putting it down picking it up putting it
back up putting it up
putting going back and forth right
here's a guy that we're supposed to
listen to that's not good mass protocol
that's not good mask protocol we're
supposed to follow your example why do
you think
trump doesn't trust fauci
well i think maybe he is looking for
consistency
in analysis and that's that's okay
but trump is one man
he is in washington dc within
three hours of him he has some of the
best
scientists in the world whether you're
talking about
mit or down in new york at corn he has
he has access to all sorts of people who
have continued to do
the studies the wall street journal
front page today says well you know what
they have finally figured it out masks
are more efficacious than
not and by the way if you want to reopen
the economy
to the maximum that you can just i'm
just talking about
money wear masks
and this economy i don't mean to be
insensitive
to the horror of this virus
this virus is agnostic the economy
only revolves around money
okay fair enough let me take it a
different angle for you here
on this topic so we've had a lot of
pandemics in the past before i mean i
went and pulled them up and i kind of
looked at the numbers because
when the pandemic happened i was in l.a
at my board meeting and de la hoya and
everybody
you know said oh we're not going to come
to the board folks from greenwich that
i'm flying
i said we're coming back so we came back
to dallas i pulled up i said let me see
what the pandemics have done in the past
top ten
and see what kind of returns they've had
i pulled up aids
pneumonic plague sars avion flu all
these fever swine cholera mers ebola and
i looked at everything to see how the
market will do
six to 12 months later how fast does it
recover right every one of them recovers
six to 12 months later except for one of
them
which is aids aids is the only one that
was minus 16 and a half 12 months later
you look at nasdaq nasdaq is now what
nasdaq is now
at uh give or take uh you know shy of
eleven thousand right it's
doing good for itself so for some that
are wondering sitting there saying
danielle
you make a very good point here's my
question for you how come we've never
shut down in the past and we've had
different pandemics why have we not shut
down
why are we shutting down this time what
is the difference
so there are two things going on first
of all
the stock market is completely divorced
from it from the economy right now
there are few who would dispute that it
is it is
not reflective of the economy or the
economy's prospects
it's reflective of the federal reserve
printing more money than they ever
have and rescuing junk rated issuers
you had record bankruptcies in june
you had record junk bond issuance in
june
these things don't tend to happen
together unless there's this artificial
force
in fact today a republican on the hill
suggested that there be an inquiry into
the fed pumping so much money
into the financial system when as best
as we can tell
the markets are doing just fine so i'll
i'll be coming to the hill myself i'll
testify if they need me
so that's one thing but
you're asking a much deeper question
it takes us back to the first time that
we visited
um in fact i spoke to my friend lynn
miller about this a few days ago
if you're flying blind in a twitter age
in a world of social media when you've
got
when you've got people up in the middle
of the night looking at satellite
imagery
over wuhan and tweeting it out the next
day
saying look at this it's got to be the
crematoriums going at night
it can't be anything else from the sky
well how would we know one way or the
other what it was
what we do know about instilling fear
and inciting fear is
nobody believes the chinese data
nobody now if you're
john or jane q world leader
and the only thing that you know about
this
virus is that it's really contagious
and that that's all you can say about it
because the chinese didn't let the world
health organization in
no data came out so you are
a scientific community flying blind into
the eye of a storm and you can't even
say
how big the storm is or isn't you just
know that it's something that was a
massive cover-up
because there was enough social media
that got in and got out
and enough imagery to scare the hell out
of you of people bodies lying dead here
and there
that you're like oh hell this is really
bad can you quantify it no
china held back with the data so we
didn't know
what the fatality rate was from day one
we just knew to be really really really
afraid of it
and if you look at places like baja
california
where 50 of people who walk through the
hospital don't walk out
with covet in countries where there are
no health
health care systems to speak of because
you know what we've gotten to be much
better at treating this thing
much much better march
new york city you enter the icu with
covid
60 chance you're dead today nationwide
42 chance we've learned how to treat
this thing
much better and we're going at it and
we're going at it fast
but we had to learn without the benefit
of the origin of this damn thing
because data were never released from
china
so it's very possible that unlike in the
past
prior to the social media age when all
information was disseminated
immediately it's possible
that there wouldn't have been this big
of a reaction we just don't know
okay so now i got to follow up for you
on that fair
so you're saying we did the right thing
shutting down that's what you're saying
i'm saying that it's
consistent with what you're saying i'm
saying that we did the right thing
shutting down i'm saying that italy did
the right thing shutting down germany
did the right thing shutting down
uk did the wrong thing shutting down too
late hurt immunity boris johnson that's
what he wanted to do until he got
coronavirus
and himself and landed in the icu they
have probably the highest
developed world death rate out there
but closing down and closing down
violently
and then requiring masks and reopening
that's a different blueprint i'm okay
with that
because again restaurants in germany are
up 20
year-over-year reservations but but to
to manage
what you're saying you are saying
shutting down
is the right choice here it was the
right choice it was the right choice
here it was
okay so now here's my follow-up okay so
is it fair to say there
will most likely be future sars
ebola coronavirus other forms of it yes
is it fair to say that when this does
happen
there's still going to be a 12 to an
18-month period where we can't figure
out a vaccine
probably okay so what you're saying to
me is
one 90 in the future
when another pandemic happens we're
going to have more shutdowns over the
next
decade or two it depends on the virus
but how do you know if you don't know
anything about the virus because what
you do know about the virus is
we don't know what the true fatality
rate is and we won't know for a while
we won't not until it gets cold again
not until we go past the risk of a
second wave
but we do know what the contagiousness
is we do know that much
and not every virus in the world is as
contagious as this thing
that much there are many other viruses
that there are not scores very high and
they still didn't shut down
the shutting down part is agreed but
again
in countries that didn't let me put let
me put it differently
are we going to be scarred by this as a
nation
by shutting down are you asking me i'm
asking you i'm asking you my questions
for
complete you're about to get a curveball
when i ask you what direction i'm going
with this
but to ask me the question are we going
to be scarred by shutting down
absolutely we are well so
are lots of countries that got whacked
by
viruses that we didn't get whacked by in
asia
and when this happened they treated it
much differently but what you're saying
is it's a new way of handling this issue
is what you're saying yes south korea
never close its restaurants
fine so so again so to go back to it we
don't have to close down in the future
president uh uh john don the future
president whoever in the future who runs
could have been a jane doe
jane doe or john doe yes or marido
whoever that runs and becomes president
it's very fair to say that they're gonna
have a lot of pressure if there's a
pandemic that they're gonna have to shut
down because they're gonna say back in
not necessarily why not no because we're
going to be scarred as a nation
we're going to say we're never going to
go back to shutting down again risk of
that president not shutting down
no i don't because nothing happened for
sure nothing happened to the president
in south korea
they didn't shut down now they emptied
out their restaurants of half the tables
they went to 50 capacity overnight
everybody put masks on and everybody's
social distance okay so and they didn't
but nothing closed down okay
so what you're saying is it's fair to
say we have another virus
the likelihood of us shutting down 50
going down to 50
restaurant we're not going to be at 100
or 75 we're going to go to 50 percent
and
james all this other stuff that stuff is
pretty much going to be protocol moving
forward
yeah modified behavior yes yes that's a
big modified behavior though but it's
not a shutdown
fine but it's still a big modified
behavior i i agree with that okay but
but but think about think about
the generation of pharmaceuticals
think about the mass manufacturer
outside of dallas
who in the aftermath of sars was
promised a government
contract but didn't get one
think about the next generation of
pharmaceuticals and personal protective
equipment that's coming to our country
coming soon to a country near you it's
your own
damn supply chain never to be relied
upon
the kindness of the people in china
again i'm with you there but we can
we can we can have our response
mechanism
can be fast but but my what i'm what i'm
thinking
and that'll create jobs what i'm asking
with this is so
in a future when another pandemic
happens
if we look at these the timeline on
these are
uh aids 81 mnemonic plague 94
sars o3 avion flute 2003 the next fever
06 swine flu 09 cholera 2010 mars 2013
ebola 20.
i mean it's not like it's once a decade
nope it's every two
three years that we have something like
this that's coming up okay so
every two or three years we should be
prepared to potentially
shut down or lower ourselves from 100 to
to 50 percent and are you also saying
because it is
the whole quantitative easing and
sending 600
per week to people to be able to save us
from going through that that ought to be
the new norm no
absolutely not okay so you're not saying
that no okay
no i'm i'm we're in dallas this is where
the one ebola person came to the whole
country in fact my pulmonologist
is the guy who gary weinstein that's my
doctor he saved my lungs
years ago for nine months i was really
sick so i
i can't jack with this covet thing
personally but he treated the one ebola
person who came to the united states
here in dallas
so ebola was kind of a good thing
because it stayed away from us we don't
know what future viruses
are going to behave like but we do know
that future leaders can be prepared
and modifying our behavior is not
shutting down the economy
you cannot equate the two and this has
been so devastating that i hope it never
happens
and the greatest fear is that we turn to
some form of socialism
because other countries will cook our
goose
period end it seems like that's what's
being proposed by a lot of people
today in politics but again so my last
question on this topic i hope
i hope that look the stimulus bill has
not been passed
and as far as i know the gop is pushing
back hard against the 600.
so we both know what industries have
taken the biggest tip i'll just read off
some of the stats so we know because i
know you know this like the back of your
hand
okay i got stats for industries
unemployment by industry i got it in may
i have it in june i'll read both of them
to you in may
leisure and hospitality unemployment 36
then he had wholesale and retail took a
hit transportation took a hit 14.2
percent
and he had construction manufacturing
11.6 and he had a few other industries
that took it okay
that's may june leisure and hospitality
came down a little bit people got some
jobs mining
core inc and oil and gas extraction 17.8
transportation and utilities 12.9
information 12
okay so that's industries car sales
stats uh number one nissa centra
q2 2020 in sales to q2
2019 sales and a half percent fewer
nissan centers have sold
this q2 over last q2 2019 they sold
53 000 nissan sentras this year's 19907
then it's nissan altima
then it's ford fusion and you have a
bunch of other cars even tesla model 3
is down 32 and a half
percent well if you're receiving an
unemployment check
just because you're not missing your
rent payment does not mean you can go
out and buy a new nissan sentra
and you the the cars that were hit the
most are the
the 25 million americans receiving that
extra 600
a week just because they're not being
evicted and just because they're not
working doesn't mean that they can go
qualify to buy a new car using financing
i mean it's just it's the fact of life
no doubt about it i am i'm asking this
question because
if today you're in your mid-20s
you graduated college i'm 22 25
30 and i'm watching this danielle i got
a question for you danielle what is it
we just talked about that they ought to
shut down and uh use the formula that
germany use or maybe south korea use and
if
fauci and trump were on the same page
fine if fauci wouldn't have said 60
minutes and been irresponsible with the
way he handles his mass with the rand
paul
fair okay if they were on the same page
and with the shutdown you know we would
have gone to mask sooner
maybe we wouldn't have the problem that
we have today but we're getting better
icu and
new york from you know march was at 60
today it's 42
we've improved 18 percent fine we're
making some progress but you said in the
future if there's another pandemic
we will most likely go the same
direction again that we may have to wear
masks we may have to go down from 100 to
to 50 possibly possibly in some
industries like jim's may have to shut
down if you're 22
25 30 years old today and you know
everything you know what industries
wouldn't you go into as a career and
what industries would you get into as a
career
so i think we've learned that a lot of
industries i mean there are a lot of
companies that are like
you know what let's make it to the end
of 2021. you can all telecommute to the
end of 2021.
lo and behold we've discovered that our
productivity has not taken a hit
and we it is it is ind
it is the industries of tomorrow it is
the innovative
bent of the future it is not industries
that require
a lot of touching and
people don't ever think of the united
states as being a low
labor cost country it's the last thing
you think of you think of all these
generations of outsourcing
to china and vietnam however
we've had a huge chunk of americans
who've been very underpaid for a
generation
and that's how small businesses have
been able to grow in this environment
they've been able to grow by virtue of
the fact that they can bring labor in
cheap
now small businesses are going to
automate now small businesses are going
to find a way of doing
hands-free transactions with their
future customers
chipotles put in all these
drive-throughs
so they can try and keep up top-line
revenues without having people come into
the restaurants
there will be whoever is the youngest
smartest graduating from medical school
right now
who is starting a nationwide
telemedicine network is going to be the
next billionaire
out there and frankly as a mother it's a
little bit too late because i've gone to
one too many pediatricians appointments
and waited in one too many doctor's
offices
when apparently i'm coming to find out
because of covet it could have all been
delivered to my home this whole damn
time
so who knew but there's going to be a
whole new generation that makes our life
a lot
easier and bring it bring it
that means that mom and dad can be more
productive you're not taking time off
from work to go sit in an office
life's going to be more streamlined in
the future and that's great
look there are there are the next
generations of manufacturing
capability in the world happens to be in
china you know what
let's bring it home let's us be the next
generation
of manufacturers industrial production
in this country has not declined since
1980 industrial production in the united
states has gone up
since 1980 employment in the
manufacturing sector has
come down as we have automated but what
we haven't done is we haven't taken it
to the next step
to where we can get beyond china and
actually
start to employ more people because
we're making things better than they do
that requires making sure that our kids
get
well educated that's hopefully something
that has come
out of this disaster is that you can't
ignore the inequality divide anymore in
this country
you can't period end you can't be like
oh that's nice i'll give to charity but
i better live in the right zip code so i
can send my kids to public school
and the heck with the rest of them no
more the inequality divide has
officially cost this country
and if we don't know that it's time to
educate our children if this
wake-up moment does not wake us up
about the need to make sure that our
kids are the future scientists
and engineers of the world there's
something really wrong with us
i'm sitting here looking at george
washington he's spinning in his grave if
we don't figure this
this out you still haven't answered my
question about
what industry would you get into well i
don't i don't know what industry i would
get into whatever the next i'm i'm not
an engineer i didn't go to engineering
school
but today what if you were if the
danielle the thing is the way you do you
have access to all the information
i would get into i would get into
computer engineering
computer engineering sure why
well one of my dear friends is one of
four
she has three brothers her three
brothers
parents told them and she's
40 years old her three brother's parents
told them you can do anything you will
pay for any graduate degree that you
want
we don't care if you want to go do
underwater basket reading
and get a phd in it we won't pay for
anything unless your undergraduate
degree is in
some form of engineering
one of them is a chemical chemical
engineer one of them is a structural
one of them is a mechanical one of them
went off to get his mba one
one of them went off to be a doctor
they're all really successful and they
have that backbone
that have that backbone to fall back on
of an engineering undergrad when i was
getting my mba
those engineers would come in hungover
broken up from playing rugby late into
the night
barely wake up take the test totally
trash the curve
blow everybody out go have a beer
afterwards while you're sitting there
worried about what you meant on the test
and how the damn engineer
blew you away again it's
it's it's discipline i would get into
anything that requires getting out of my
comfort zone
and having to learn the math and the
science that you don't want to learn
would any of the way the coronavirus was
handled or potentially a future pandemic
could
change a lot of industries and put them
out would you avoid any industries maybe
let me ask the question that way
would you would you avoid giving advice
to somebody saying if there's anything i
can tell
you i would avoid getting involved in
this industry i would avoid getting into
this industry on this one
well i mean it's easy enough to say i
don't have
great aspirations for my kids to grow up
and become waitresses or
or the lady who does my manny petty
which involves
human contact here's a different way
okay but i will tell you this much
i will answer the question in a
different way
a lot of a lot of the
consulting firms of the world right now
are realizing because their clients are
truly it's not like a minor industrial
recession like we had in 2015 and 2016.
this is like a really big kid recession
it really is it's pull up your underwear
it's it's this is serious stuff
a lot of consultants
are going to be a little bit redundant
going forward
when companies have to be a lot meaner
and a lot leaner
than they are today i think business
travel is going to take a generation to
come back
a generation a generation to come back
people are going to study how much money
they used to spend on travel and
expenses
and realize that they were able to bring
together in the heat of the crisis
people from coast to coast and by the
way joe you know whoever's in
korea he can come on in too because we
don't he doesn't
we don't have to fly in business class
to come to this meeting in new york
that's going to cost the company god
knows how much money we're all getting
together because zoom is
yesterday we've got the next generation
of zoom
we can smell the other guy across the
world's got bad breath at this point
the technology's coming and companies
are going to save a lot of money and
they're going to realize that they can
save a lot of money
without i'm not naming names but without
having mckenzie or bain or deloitte
have to come in and say this is how you
should approach this problem
you give an executive who's going to
come out on the other end who's still an
executive
of a company they're going to realize
that there was a lot of fat in between
that they'd been sold by corporate
america
so the the 165 starting salary at
mckenzie with a 35 000 signing bonus is
gone that damn engineer who got it and
bought a 911 the day of graduation
i'm telling you he did this is changing
the game
by the way so okay let me ask it a
different way here's a different way
you're an advisor we have a bunch of
entrepreneurs
they have millions of dollars to buy
businesses okay
so they they're not going to be waiter
or waitress but they may buy a
restaurant with a good chef they may buy
into real estate they may buy into
technologies they may buy into different
things
if i'm somebody that's not necessarily
the guy that just wants to invest and be
a passive i want to put my money into
business and start a company what
industries would you look at
business not a job or career the
businesses that i would look into would
be healthcare number one
healthcare number one healthcare number
one why is that i mean we're trying to
kill the baby boomers
but we're not going to succeed there's
going to be some left
and and the way that they're delivered
medicine
the future of medicine and my
generations
not getting any younger so i think that
the
i think and there's no reason that there
should be a 10x differential between
what you spend on a mask in china and
what you spend on a mask in the united
states
somebody's going to figure out how to
make this stuff cheaper so
you're talking about really tight minds
that that know how to not just innovate
but innovate
smartly one-up them but
but i think i think telecom is one i
think that
there will be a different way that we
we're not going to stop going on
vacation
we're in a big pause period right now we
don't want to go into high rises anymore
up and down
elevators necessarily we're kind of
leery and weary of
air conditioning systems but you know
what
the flight that i took out to los
angeles recently what i was told
i was told that the pilots and the
co-pilots
sitting up in the front of the of the
plane have always had
the clean air systems can't have them
getting sick
rest of the plane screw them but can't
have the guys in the front getting sick
it was just a matter of expensing
spending the money to deploying it
there are going to be there are going to
be young entrepreneurs in america
who come in and say your office building
i'm converting it
there's going to be uv rays everywhere
if a germ wants to even
make itself present no i've got
technology
i love that that's going to zap
everything quietly there's no chemicals
involved
nada flying's going to be safe
going to the office is going to be safe
going to a hotel is going to be safe
i mean when i sit in a hotel recently
they removed the stationary
i mean it was like walking into a prison
cell a very expensive one because they
had to remove
everything that could have germs on it
possibly no there's a technology out
there for that
and it's going to be applied everywhere
until we we're like fine whatever so
there's a new virus
i'll put my mask on when i go to the
grocery store if i don't have it i had
my sam's club delivered today thank you
very much
gave the person a nice tip we all tip
nicer these days don't we we all tip
nicer and we should
because we're like they're on the front
lines they're they're the ones out there
doing the things that we don't want to
do therefore you tip higher
but i had all my sam's club delivered
today but if if the time you know
if for the next pandemic and we know
it's coming
because this this puppy is some kind of
gradation of
of coronavirus and hiv
in younger people it attacks it attacks
the organs like hiv attacked the organs
so god knows what the next generation of
virus is going to look like but
there will be people who come out and
invest in business lines that
make the world a safer place such that
that the gravity of the shutdown will
never have to be reality again
somebody's going to make millions of
billions off of that
yeah i was at four seasons in dallas and
the floors to go up the elevator this
you can't stay in those rooms the only
ones that are available is the bungalows
so the whole thing with cone through
elevators they were uncomfortable doing
that
but at west palm at breakers yesterday
they had no problem they kept the
elevators open if you think about that
yeah four but four people max is what
they kept it and there was
sanitize there was masks everywhere
sanitizer so they had a system for doing
that but
you know we're talking about it but i'd
rather zap the air yeah i mean that that
would be the ultimate
is if we can do that here's a question
for you you're in the business i'm in
the financial industry
financial industry is the lowest for
having taken a hit
why is that why is unemployment the laws
and financial and insurance
well the fed has been very kind tell me
more
so the beauty of
jay powell pulling out the bazooka and
quantitative easing the likes of which
he's done and
making sure that companies because you
have to understand the math okay this is
pretty simple
non-financial businesses that just means
all businesses in america except for
banks
so non-financial debt as a percentage of
gdp
on december the 31st 2019 was 74 percent
that is a record in u.s history normally
again very simple math normally your
non-financial debt to gdp
peaks out during a recession right
because your gdp goes down your
denominator goes down
so as a percentage of gdp it picks up
prior to going into recession
at the end of 2019 74 record high
including any and all us recessions
awful we were ready for not a black swan
not the coronavirus we were ready for a
sneeze because we had over leveraged
ourselves
so much so since
then and the fed knew it so
since then from
january the 1st until june the 30th
non-financial debt
in the united states has grown 2.5
trillion dollars why
because the fed forced open the markets
by saying
we will buy junk bond this is moral
hazard
the risk return that math is gone
you can take the risk we'll handle the
return don't worry we've got you covered
to quote jay pal we'll make you whole
so what happens when a company that
should have gone bankrupt
like a casino operator or a
really indebted cruise line or a hotel
chain that was up to their eyeballs in
debt
when you say you know what instead of
restructuring
because your balance sheet is terrible
and you should go into restructuring and
your creditors should lose and your
shareholders instead of that
let's instead give you more debt fine
what does that do for american banks
what does that do for the financial
industry
45 billion dollars in fee and trading
income
in the second quarter alone to the five
largest banks in america
a little gift from jay powell
that helps them offset the 25 billion
dollars that they had to set aside
for future loan losses good business if
you can get into it
not american but it's a damn good
business
what would you have done i would have
let the bad companies go
it's kind of it's capitalism it's how it
works
yeah we talked about this last time we
did but you know what's different
between now and then
two and a half trillion dollars and you
know what that means when these
companies do eventually go bankrupt
that means that people lose their jobs
because there's much less value to be
carved out of a restructuring process
because you put that much more debt back
on the balance sheet
so you're not talking about the future
bankruptcies of america because these
are insolvent badly-run companies
you're talking about a liquidation and
that really upsets me
yeah it makes you think when you're when
you're looking at this because
you know do you think there's another
element where the financial industry is
also doing well because they've learned
how to adjust to sell through zoom and
no longer have to do the face-to-face or
do you think that was already going on
prior to it
i mean that's that's part of it but if
if the stock market wasn't at all time
highs how would the financial industry
be doing
it it's kind of
j pal still can't let the stock market
go the stakes are higher than they've
ever been
so you don't have to be a financial adv
there's not much advice to give
own the stock market dot dot dot don't
do anything else just own this by the
way gold has done very well i wonder why
that is
but that's not what a financial advisor
is going to tell you about because
they're not going to make money if you
own gold
they're going to make money if you're
along the stock market and so what
they've had to tell their clients has
not
changed over the last several months
even with the price of 18 17 as of today
do you still recommend buying gold
i still recommend having a large portion
of your portfolio in gold what does
large mean define
large i think 10 is too low
oh 10 is too low i think so
you know the numbers typically been five
percent i know i understand that but if
we're going into a different kind of
economic regime
i mean we had a falling interest rate
environment for 38 years
these trends tend to take a while if
let's say we end up with socialism in
america or some variant of it
i think inflation is going to rear its
ugly head if we keep the printing
presses going
socialists say we can go forever and
ever and ever
we can't foreigners own 36 percent of
outstanding us treasuries we still kind
of need them to come to our auctions
now what if they start demanding a
higher price to own our paper
little different dynamic kind of makes
you wonder where that gold and silver in
your portfolio is
what do you think could go what do you
think that number could go to oh
that that that you're asking the wrong
person that i'm
i'm no i'm no technician i'm no chartist
i just know that i sleep better at night
because a good friend of mine who is one
of the best investors i know
said to me danielle it's not he said a
hedge is not five percent of a portfolio
he said how much how much of a hedge is
five percent gonna gonna be
if your other 95 percent melts like it's
how much do you want that
how much do you want that five percent
to carry did he say his hedge what did
he write he is 25
okay he's twenty-five percent okay now
is it fair to say he's a very
conservative guy
it's fair to say he's a very smart guy
he's not a sheep he's he's anything but
a sheep
and he's certainly not short the stock
market either he's not that stupid he
doesn't short this
no okay look one of the things on
twitter that is so
irritating is if you say that stocks are
overvalued
you get these tweeds come back come back
at you saying oh you're just bitter
because you're
short the stock market i'm like i don't
know how you equate one with the other
buddy
but there are many other ways to make
money in this world
than shorting the stock market or being
long the stock market did you see what
elon musk did with the shorts he sold to
all the people that shorted tesla and he
said here's a tesla shorts did you see
that
i i heard about that yes he's one
wealthy man isn't he
yes he is he's what do you think about
him
i i cried when the spacex thing went up
so
so you're a fan you're supportive of
what he's doing you're ex you know you
like seeing an entrepreneur like that
keep innovating
but does it concern you a little bit i
worry about his shareholders
are you one hell no
why not because it's not
worth more than i think it's united
kingdom
germany and i think tesla stock is
worth several countries right now you
don't think it's worth more than toyota
it just passed toyota i'm thinking no
why is that maybe in the future it is
but that was the type of valuation
that we were discussing in 1999.
well if you just look far enough out at
the potential for spacex
possibly but china has plenty of
electric vehicle makers right now
that are in a very bad way
more importantly india is not ready yet
if there was a country with china at a
30-low
30-year low growth rate if if if india
was ready to take the baton
right now if they had oh i don't know
infrastructure a highway system
the ability for that 1.6 billion to be
even on a
minor growth trajectory to get enough
income to afford
a lot of little electric vehicles much
less have the roads to drive
drive them on i would say that the
future looked different
but that's not the case so
you have to have enough humans to put in
these vehicles
you have to have enough roads to put the
vehicles on in the case of india which
is the next demographic growth country
or the
the middle east is another very good
demographic
um backdrop as well you have to find
countries
but it might have been south america
maybe
but what covett has done to south
america
it's taking i've written extensively
over the past few months
i have friends in colombia i have
friends medellin was the
the silicon valley of of south america
what's happening in this country on
those countries is just
beyond devastating it's going to take
them back 50 years
what's happening with covid it's just
there's a and there's you know i was
talking to my friend about this there's
china's not gonna buy all the copper in
the world anymore and all the iron ore
in the world anymore
and that that propped up so much of
south america
we have to think about these things you
don't think that opens up an opportunity
for india to compete with china or no
you think india is decades away
i think that i think that there are
already
companies that are that are making great
inroads
with india the corruption is is
difficult to get past
worse than china especially their land
laws
and you kind of need strong land laws to
lay down
road so that that's been one of the
hindrances to making inroads with india
because the potential is there i have a
friend who's got factories in india the
potential is
is right there it is but
but again it's right now you're at a
different stage
of their growth not one that elon musk
can take advantage of tomorrow
you know we were talking about when i
asked you industry you said if you had
to do it all over again today the
industry would consider is healthcare is
what you said right you said
today if i was starting all over today
post covert you would consider health
care right
just just this this is just hormone you
know and health care is getting
decimated but yes yes so for this is for
myself so i looked at unemployment by
age
okay may 2019 versus may 2020
by age 16 to 19
uh unemployment went from 12.6 to 29.9
which is not that bad as 2.37 times
worse
20 to 24 is 3.31 times worse
25 to 34 is 3.82 times worse
35 to 44 is also about 3.78
45 to 54 unemployment went from 2.6 to
2.7
but 55 and over it went from 2.7
to 11.8 it's the worst out of all of
them why do you think
boomers are taking the biggest anatomy
boomers 55 and up
are getting let go and fired more than
the rest
there's a good reason for this and that
age cohort has
just been decimated and these will be
permanent job losses if you think about
boomers
who lost their shirt in 2008 and 2009
and lo and behold the portfolio that i
have the ira that i have the 401k that i
wouldn't
it will it will unless i die quick
unless i unless i put dying on my
calendar
in the next few years then i need to go
back to work
and so what do they do they're greeters
at walmart
they're checkout people at home depot
they're gate agents for southwest
they're hand-to-hand they're tactile
people they're in industries where
they're the face you want to see
but that's no longer the case now we're
trying to reduce the number
of people yeah but if they if they take
the head and they can't find an income
that's a bigger cost on america because
somebody has to take care of them right
look you have seen
if you thought that the italian style
doubling and tripling up
multiple generations under one roof
pre-covered was bad
you're going to see i mean people are
asking me all the
expert on housing people ask me all the
time what is the future of housing and
i'm like
three generations one roof
baby boomers going not going to be able
to get back into the workforce and and
the fastest
well i'm wrong i said that wrong the
most consistently growing age cohort for
the past
12 years has been those 55 and older
month in and month out you've seen them
add to the ranks of
the the workforce they own homes
they own a lot of homes but so what's to
become of them
and the millennials have also lost quite
a bit of work
but i think that in the years to come
you're going to have multiple
generations like you see in italy
under one roof and that's going to
resolve the baby boomers having
being way too high on real estate
what generation took the biggest hit
would you say boomers
to be determined because the stock
market an all-time high
once
once we go through what we're going
through what we're starting to go
through which is the
the beginning of the w we're seeing
activity in the past two weeks we're
seeing hotel occupancy rates we're
seeing daily rates at hotels come back
down we're seeing
um we're seeing um tsa throughput come
down
since july the fourth we're seeing a lot
of activity get pulled back
as vacations get cancelled business
trips get cancelled people are like
finally venturing out and they're like
hell i gotta bring it back in
once we get through this next wave i
think and
we have seen initial jobless claims stop
improving
we saw that last week for the very first
time that's that improvement's gone
so once we see joblessness starts start
to creep back
up and i think the stock market will get
the memo
then you ask me which generation's been
hurt the most
because too early to tell baby boomers
but they've got a lot of home
and they're relying on their portfolios
and not much
age in front of them to to resolve it
makes sense make sense uh
are you buying these polls saying that
biden's gonna be trump
let me tell you about where i live
where i live four years ago
there were signs in front of everybody's
houses
one way or the other more of trump
for sure than there were for clinton
you drive through my neighborhood today
you'd never know that election was
taking place
no signs anywhere nobody saying
anything in private company
doesn't even come up as a subject
three political action committees with
republican money behind them
to elect biden
so i don't know what the silence means
i don't put much i don't put much in
polling
because the polls were completely wrong
and
trump rode into office showing us that
the polls
were wrong the polls were saying that
brexit wasn't going to happen and it did
so until they come up with a better
methodology for polling
i'm not going to put too much stock in
it but i can tell you
that the drive-by the way that warren
buffett used to assess
companies if i can kick them in the
tires and i can figure out what they are
then i'll buy them
fine i can't kick this election in the
tire
because nobody's saying what they're
doing i don't even see bumper stickers
nothing it's quiet
that tells me that biden will probably
win
but i don't know that tells you biden
will probably win
who are you more comfortable with i
don't know tell me who his vice
presidential candidate is going to be
okay which vice presidential candidate
would make you feel more comfortable
with him
i've always liked mike pence i'll tell
you that much
so i'm not going to answer your question
you just did
you just did well biden's not going to
choose trump i mean biden's not going to
choose pence
that's the point i understand
look remember i'm sending two of my
bulls boys off to culvert military
academy
which is on you know it's
half a mile from where pence's family
lives pence
pre trump i'm walking through the
indianapolis
airport i've been writing about unfunded
pensions for my entire career
and i'm walking through the indianapolis
airport which is a great airport by the
way
very clean and i'm reading this
billboard that says
our pension's the most funded in america
and i'm like
my hero who is this person so i stop i
google i stop boys google it
governor state of in indiana this is
june of 2016. i've never heard of mike
pence
what a way to look at it well i'm a
fiscally conservative person
i believe in balancing the budget i
believe in
bringing down the growth of debt in
america
and he is a fiscally conservative proven
person i don't think that
biden will be that wait he's already
said he won't be
it's a matter of public record yeah he
said he's going to raise taxes and they
clap forward
uh is who who else in the marketplace if
they ran you'd get behind them
if there was another person running
right now you you get behind him
or her well i've always found mark
cuban's approach to the covid
pandemic to be very rational i've
listened to him closely
so my mother likes him i mean look
anybody who my mom likes
i have to like well i mean it's
dangerous if you don't but she's oh
honey have you heard him he's on tv
so um so if cuba ran today you'd vote
for you you'd be excited about him
well i'm a mavericks fan too that helps
but yes but he did say
if you want to address what's wrong with
small business in america
put a push push a pause button just
provide for overdraft protection for
those small business owners until we get
past the worst of this
don't don't don't even take it to
congress don't even
don't go there don't go down there with
them push a pause button
keep all the small businesses in america
open they'd still be open today if we'd
taken that
i know sometimes keep it simple stupid
is the wrong it's does not belong in
washington dc
but we need a different way of doing
politics in america today and there are
a lot more people
who are coming out and talking openly
about it
this is a magnificent opportunity a
friend of mine asked me a few days ago
danielle
who would win the election if it was one
year out
considering how many people would be
able to run instead
what'd you say i said mark cuban
you know here's a question for you you
know and i'm not some mark cuban
huge fan or anything he's just one
person i've listened to talk about
economically the pandemic in a rational
logical manner
that doesn't hurt my wallet yeah
you know how uh uh people
say they look at your relationship or
your marriage or your
way of handling any situation and
they'll say you know what if i were her
i wouldn't have done that you know if i
were him i wouldn't if i were
if i were if i would and we all do it
right everybody does if i were it's a
fun game to play if i were right
i hate to do it but okay but you know
and and
if i were a game we always are
the wiser one the person saying it is
always a wiser one smarter one it's more
sophisticated because we sound better
saying
if i were we don't have access to the
whole situation you know i wonder how
much of these
if i were president i would have done
dot dot
they actually would have done because
everybody sounds like more of a
presidential president before they
become a president and then they become
a president and
90 of them don't do what they said they
were going to do so
you find somebody who says what he's
going to then you don't like it he gets
present he becomes a president and he
does what he said you didn't like he was
going to do at least you got to respect
the fact that he said
he was going to do what he was going to
do i just wonder how many of these guys
actually
will do what they say they're going to
do but i don't think it's one person
i think it's a country
i think it's the middle
think about think about the united
states population today as a barbell
you got the people over here whose
backsides are covered by
fiscal stimulus make sure they don't get
evicted make sure blah blah blah blah
blah
600 extra week they're covered their
spending is barely down
think of the people over here who were
like hell if they raise taxes that much
i'll move to new zealand
i'll just leave the country i'll go
think about the people in the middle
who've closed their small businesses
who've worked hard their whole lives who
tried their best to keep their payrolls
going
who are suffering not by any fault of
their own
whose economy is closed down again
putting the nail in the coffin
of their future for a while
i want this portion of america to come
together
and not get behind one man or one woman
but a whole different way
i believe in long cycles but it takes a
lot
to trigger the rise of a third party in
america but if this
again isn't sufficient what is
my oldest is 16 years old he's voting in
the midterm elections
i hope that the midterm elections are
going to be a pivotal turning point in
this country
i hope that we see that it's not one man
or the other that's going to fix the
situation
because it's not it's bigger than one
person
you have to get i'm not ugh during the
swamp i didn't want to say it
but you have to come to a whole
different way of approaching
politics in america that gets rid of all
this red tape all this bureaucracy
to where you can get enough people in
office who are rational
to get something done and you can't just
say that because there's no term limits
fine we have a constitution bring a
referendum around
i mean if there are enough people in the
middle who still love this country
then we can change the constitution we
can impose term limits
these are things we can do and we should
do them
but no you're right it's not one person
it's not one person
because how many have gone off to
washington with all the hopes and dreams
and
aspirations and i'm gonna stay clean and
then why i need four more years
i just need one more term i'll get it
done then
and they become part of the system
that's why you don't need one or two
great leaders
you need a huge ass wide swath
of them somebody needs to be the voice
though someone is great
to represent that so you're saying a
third party you think we're ready for it
i think we're i think we're beyond ready
for a third party what do you call that
third party independent libertarian or a
new party
i could care less it needs a whole new
name
not independent or libertarian a whole
new name libertarians have been trying
at it for how long
well they have boring candidates thank
you gosh they have boring and
i had to text somebody a few days ago
and say who's this person i mean we
talked about in the podcast i said
please stop with these videos there's
just
nice person she seems sweet but come on
you need a
person that's going to get out there and
be a little bit bolder so bold
yeah so is it more individual or is it
more party
because there's got to be somebody you
get behind you need
someone to be the voice you need
somebody
and a bunch of people behind them also
running for a bunch of
important senate and house seats at the
same time
you're looking at a you know you're not
looking at an eight year run though
you're not making changes in eight years
though
i'm not dead yet no i know that but what
i'm saying and they say that this
generation z is on fire
yeah they say gen z is ready to rock and
roll ready to work hard
if we i mean if we need a change agent
apparently we've got them
have you ever talked to trump's camp or
no yeah
you ever spoken to pence camp no never
have
i speak with a secret service
contingency when i'm driving around
culver when he's got his family reunion
there but that's the closest
as i've come what are your aspirations
with politics you sound like you're
you know you could you could really
inspire some people i am happy to back
any movement that's rational i really am
i have a voice i'm i clearly i'm not
quiet
i'm ready to use my voice to bring about
change in this country because i love my
children and i want their future to be
different
do you have plans of running no at all
yeah why not
it could be past my time
i think we need somebody young we need
it we need to you know what do you tell
me it's past your time
we need a kennedy but not his politics
but we need somebody who is
young and charismatic and can pull the
whole country together yeah but you're
you're not you're saying it's not just
presidency you're saying other positions
other positions
so but here's a problem you ready people
who are smart like you who have great
lives
don't want to run don't want to run
what do you want to do i mean you want
to fix it but you don't want to run
maybe maybe i'd be like the person who
finds people
no you'd be like the retirement i'll go
recruit people i will
there's a long time between now and
2022.
but see that's the challenge in a world
of social media
the runway's compressed yeah you can get
the information out there quicker than
you used to be able to we're not in the
dark anymore well i mean i don't know if
you know or not the interview we did
your videos were picked up by
saudi arabia and it got like five six
million views and it was all over the
place and nowadays with social media
you're being heard all over the world
it's no longer a
uh message that you're just hearing in
one place just a quick question for you
did you
did you see what ted cruz and mark cuban
had going on today no i did not okay so
let me read it and see what you think
about it so a guy named mark davis
sends a tweet at cuban i'm so ready to
be on this year's maverick home straight
so much promise so much personality
but the minute one player kneels during
the anthem
i'm out surely mark cuban i think he
says surely mark cuban uh uh he
continues to say some words about who
what mark cuban would do mark cuban
turns around and says
bye okay to the guy he just says bye
meaning don't come now this gets
a hundred thousand likes and a bunch of
retweets okay
then right afterwards ted cruz says
really nba is telling everyone who
stands for the flag who honors our cops
and our veterans to piss off in texas no
less good luck with that
mark cuban comes back and says have some
balls for once ted cruz
speak to me it's my tweet ted cruz comes
back and says speaking of balls tell us
what you think about china
i'll wait this is all happening today in
the last four i did not know this
so then it continues and says i think i
won't criticize uh
if you think i won't criticize china
what they do as concerns american
citizens watch this video et cetera et
cetera
anyways they go back and forth and then
he says why is it ted cruz that you take
such pride
in standing up to and speaking truth to
the chinese but you have no ability to
stand up and speak the truth
to president trump so the concern with
cuban as a candidate is his position
to china and obviously for obvious
reasons because
first of all stop for a minute because
there is no kneeling for my flag
i stand for my flag zero for you zero
tolerance
you're a maths fan if they start being
okay with kneeling what do you do
i'm no longer a mass fan you're being
serious about this
i think that the missing link in america
today
is that patriotism is some kind of
conditionality
there's no conditionality about being an
american you either are or you're not
you either stand for the flag or you
don't there are people who died for that
flag
i don't think there's no wiggle room
around it i'm sorry
but you should be proud to be a patriot
and you should be proud of this flag
and you should be proud of making the
next generation proud to also not kneel
if you don't like what's happening in
this country do something about it
but don't disparage those who've died
for you ever and by the way ted cruz put
a mask on
and this is coming from somebody that
actually is a fan of mark cuban it's not
like you're against mark cuban well your
position is strong with military and i
respect that a lot
going to what ted cruz said about china
and mark cuban china
why do you think so many people in
america business people are so
protective of china
business people are not protective of
china you don't think so i think there's
a movement against
you think so oh i can name many many
billionaires that are
whatever are there hedge fund guys who
want to play the system
yeah there are a lot of big businesses
who realize that china's been stringing
them along for a generation saying
we're going to open the country we're
going to give you an opportunity to have
great operations
they're lying to them there was a great
article recently i can't remember where
i read it but there was a great article
recently where
american companies have finally woken up
to the fact
that they're not going to make major
inroads on the mainland
okay that there's not going to be the
next generation of electronic payments
alibaba is already there it's finished
china invites in american companies
after it's completely finished
saturating its own market
it's an insult i agree a complete insult
and it's
it's better known that it's ever been
because
all of a sudden in boardrooms across
america
ceos cfos boards are being said
a trade war is one thing killing
americans is another
figure out a new supply chain and figure
it out now
this is not a trade war this is not
optionality
anymore figure out a new supply chain
you think the left and the right is all
on the same page with that
i don't think that biden i don't i don't
think
that karl marx could pull back what
we've learned about china
i think if there's one service if
there's one service that's been done
it is a greater recognition of the fact
that it's not about soybeans and it's
not about corn
it's about 5g
and other countries are figuring this
out
look what look at what china's trying to
do to australia
look at what china's trying to do to its
other to countries that have benefited
from chinese policies for years and
years
for these countries to stand up to china
and say
had you released the data on the
pandemic maybe we
australia would not have shut down and
we wouldn't be going into the first
recession in 40 years
but australia led the independent
inquiry at the world health organization
to look into the origin of the virus and
was backed by 116 countries
116 countries and australia benefits
arguably more than any other country in
the world with their natural resources
exports
and they still stood up to china i think
that there will be a change
and we don't need the change in our farm
in our farmland
and lives from china about how much they
can or will buy
i'm happy that they're buying american
american soybeans that's fantastic but
don't come into my 5g network
and other countries are figuring it out
and it can't just be one country
because it's the next it's the next
the china's artificial intelligence
their robotics
their 5g these are the things that
americans need to be doing
you're asking me about 20 to 25 year
olds
one-up china at what they're doing and
make sure that they can never
have espionage become a part of taking
us down again
and yes a lot of countries and companies
companies both are figuring it out
i agree with worldwide i agree with a
lot of countries are turning their backs
on china
but companies in the united states are
as well i don't think the nba is and i
do not think hollywood is i think those
two industries are
so reliant on the need to have china
play
nba games and china play hollywood
movies that they're
so frightened of saying anything about
one
gm from houston says stand up to hong
kong and what's going on he gets
hollered and lebron you're you're out of
line and he wasn't prepared what he said
nothing against china they'll say
anything against anybody but they
protect china
anything against anybody except for
china they'll call out the president
they'll call out the businesses they'll
call out any other place that they they
will not touch china
have you been following this with the
nba in hollywood i have tangentially i
don't follow hollywood very closely
because i don't listen to too many
people in hollywood very closely
so it's can't i think you would like
ricky gervais i don't know if you saw
ricky could you raise his speech or not
uh
yes okay he's he's one person you ought
to follow you say barking like a seal
yes that was me um but
but to your point about the nba to your
point about kowtowing to china
for any reason
if that is a requirement that we bend
for commerce then
then the future of this country as i
describe the barbell of the
paying people not to work and being
filthy rich and there being nothing in
the in the middle
no middle class no middle income earners
no entrepreneurs no small business
owners
if that's our future then we've been
forever or
you know will the real american raise
their hand
and not let this happen
we spoke in april 7th you said something
about china that
was picked up all over the place uh on
how the way they signed the contract and
the agreement is right on the dates etc
etc that if they do they're protecting
themselves
fine how bad
do you think china is going to pay a
price for what they did
at this point this is july what are we
today july what
20 july 20th that was april 7th when we
spoke how bad is china going to pay
price for what they did
well what china is not going to do is
crash
they can manage their decline they've
been carefully
and methodically managing their decline
for years fake data
they can continue to manage that decline
but they're not in the position of
strength
that they would have the rest of the
world believe
and what this virus has done has
weakened that position
further that's why they've signed
a 25-year secret agreement with iran
for security purposes it's not like it
was on the front page of the wall street
journal it was in some places but it was
on wall street
right no i'm with you a hundred percent
they are definitely trying 45 billion
46 billion to build alliances
and you wouldn't be building alliances
if you didn't feel like you had to
they've got very little good will left
on the entire continent of africa
very little they're not going to have
much good will left in south america
because what we were talking about
they're not going to buy all
the copper and all the iron ore from
those countries at a time when those
countries economies
are devastated and
they've shown their true stripes
to countries that they're supposedly
friends up with so
china is not going to crash and
everybody wants that to be the case
but if you can print money and then tell
bankers at gunpoint to put it into the
economy which we cannot do
you can manage the decline but how
strong they are going forward is a
different
story so to think that there is this
narrative that the united states is in a
position of weakness
vis-a-vis china is wrong absolutely
wrong and this pandemic
has been beneficial if you're looking at
war games
so to speak to us to the united states
who else do you think china is getting
close to you think china you think
russia and putin trust
china right now i don't think russia
trusts anybody
but russia likes to be there
russia russia just likes to have an
invitation to the party
they just want to be sure that everybody
knows that they've got tanks and they've
got oil but they don't have much else
other than that but they do have a
really long border
with china yeah and that alliance is
pretty good saudi arabia possibly
russia's like the brother who keeps in
contact with your ex
that's a really good way to put it very
weird what are you doing my ex
yeah like let it go you know we broke up
you're supposed to be on this side but
it's very weird what
russia does they have an interesting way
of doing things russia likes to
russia russia's like that itch you can't
scratch
yeah they do they like to make trouble
it's what russia does
yeah because they're not dominant and
they never will be again but they can
but that's not to say that that that
china can't build alliances
last last question here for you so i
have my thoughts i'm curious to know
what you think i mean you saw how bad
the protests got at one point
and it was pretty ugly going back and
forth do you think
since we're in july right now you got
july august september october november
okay goldman sachs said
the election this year is going to be
very similar to the one with gore and
bush the fact that they're not going to
finally
they're not going to know who wins for
another three weeks and
gore and bush was 35 days they feel this
one's going to be the same way that
we're not going to know the news right
off the bat and they're going to have to
recount et cetera et cetera okay
fine no problem what are your
your opinion about how ugly things are
going to get in the next
few months could we potentially have
something close to civil war or do you
think things are going to get pretty
peaceful the next four months with the
election
i think that politics in america today
is about money and i think that people
with money
are aware of the risk that you describe
and if you
can buy elections which you can in this
country
then you can get rid of that gray area
if you want to put enough money
towards it
i speak code but can you unpack the code
you just shared like
buy what election so if i can buy the
biden election if i can win that and
then i'm gonna eliminate a lot of the
headaches
if there's a landslide everything you're
talking about goes away
i don't think it's going to happen
we'll find out but remember there aren't
any political signs
in my neighborhood when you drive home
tonight look in your neighborhood
and you get back to me and tell me if
you see political signs it's very quiet
out there
there's one and last four years ago
there was like 50.
there was only one when you said i went
straight to my community and i thought
about
the drive i make to go see where the
signs are to see which neighbor is what
we have none of it right now it's just
one
now when i was in florida yesterday we
went to hillsboro
we were looking at homes all over fort
lauderdale hillsborough and
bulk and all these places rio vista and
we saw boats i've never seen
this many boats with trump flags
i tell you mario did you see one with
biden no
well i haven't seen any bite in anything
i couldn't believe
it was just trump trump trump trump
trump and my realtor
kind of his backyard i mean isn't it
mar-a-lago no it is but but
but our driver our bus driver was like
oh we hate him here
we were driving by past marlocas tell me
why who hates them here oh everybody
hates them why
and i thought she was going to give a
political answer she said because every
time he comes to visit his family do you
know he shuts down the road because he
wants all the privacy and people get off
work at four o'clock we have to wait
three hours
i thought you were gonna give me like a
you know what he said all she thought
about is traffic so that's how we hate
the guy
like you know what hey i can respect
that it's it's one that affects think
about it
the top one percent they own those boats
and they've done very well under trump
yes yes they have i think that is true
so daniel why don't we tell everybody
what we're doing
why don't we let's tell them let's tell
them i'm excited because the last time
uh when when we sat down we spoke
uh afterwards uh i sat down to talk
tomorrow i'm like you know what i think
i think she has so much to offer i think
she needs a platform for her to
constantly
share her thoughts because the audience
wants to know so much and that's when i
reached out i said let's get on the
phone you and i got together and i said
danielle how about you become a host on
valuetainment
and then we went back and forth and then
you said yes
let's do it and i'm excited to announce
to all of you
that you are looking at one of the
latest hosts on valuetainment she'll be
doing interviews and some other kind of
content
and we're very excited about it and if
you're excited about it as much as we're
excited about it
comment below your thoughts and in the
description section we're going to put a
link
to any of our latest interviews now you
got two big ones that are coming up
which we'll let the audience know when
it comes out
uh click on a link below it'll take you
to exactly where those videos are gonna
be
and if you have anything that you want
to see then he'll talk about
or make videos on also put in the
comment section we want to know about it
danielle i'm very excited to have you as
a host on valuetainment valuetainment
economics here we come it's going to be
exciting so i haven't
said that uh this was a wonderful
conversation thank you for your time
looking forward to what the future has
told for all of us likewise
thank you so we're very excited to
introduce obviously daniel demartino
booth has a new host on valuetainment
economics which is exciting time so
i got a couple things i want to do with
you if you've not watched her first
interview we did
click over here to watch her interview
and second thing is to watch
all of her content and adam sosnick's
content on valuetainment economics
click on this link to go to the new
channel please subscribe
because many of the content on money and
economics will be on this channel having
said that
thank you for watching everybody take
care bye
you